foreign
comes from Wesley in Arizona
I've been hearing oh man anytime
somebody starts with having here and oh
here we go I've been hearing more and
more in the news recently about the
government looking at digital currency
are they doing away with cash and if so
should I be worried some are suggesting
taking money out of the bank and
investing it in gold or silver
that's not something I feel comfortable
with but I don't want to lose my money
they're coming for us Dave
you got a little prepper down inside of
you oh way down in there I'm worried
about some and I've been hearing
yeah they're coming for us they said and
I heard or a really crummy financial
planning firm
um especially when you're getting it off
the internet because everything on the
internet is true Abraham Lincoln said
that so um
okay
um
first let's understand
that actual
paper money
is a very small percentage of our
economy already
that when you venmo someone when you
write a check to someone when you use
your debit card to someone
when you have an automatic withdrawal
from your checking account to someone
100 of the money that transferred was
digital money you've never written me an
actual check Dave it just deposits in my
account right yeah all of my payroll is
not done with real money it's done with
digital money
[Music]
cue the UFO music
okay so um dude we're already I don't
know what the percentage is but what
would you guess I mean what percentage
of our economy is paper money and what
percent of digital transfers as we just
discussed just guessing I'd say 95 at
least yeah really high in the high 90s
it's got to be our our digital transfers
here's what I know I recently bought
some concert tickets for like a bunch of
us and I had everybody pay me back I
still don't understand how to get venmo
from venmo into my checking account so I
said hey yo guys got to bring me checks
and you I might as well said hey I want
you all to all um just wear your bathing
suits over to my house for dinner like
it was this they looked at me like I was
from Mars and they all wrote checks and
they were all written in like like
they'd written with their feet like they
didn't know how to do it like little
children wrote the check yeah and Sheila
was like man I don't know how you have a
friend did they graduate from we Wesley
you and me brother we can uh we can
count our silver coins when it all goes
down the woods so um really my point is
to do away with cash and coins would
really not
uh disrupt most of the economy most
people most of the time most people most
of the time I mean I I was in the gas
station the other day and a guy bought a
pack of gum with his debit card and I'm
like really you don't have a dollar I
mean you don't have two dollars I mean
he because people just I mean especially
depending on your age group right old
fart like me I've always got a couple
hundred dollar bills I got a redneck
emergency fund there's always thousand
thousand dollars a thousand dollars and
hundreds tucked somewhere in my clothing
right but the uh uh oh my gosh but the
yeah but young people they're just like
oh It's All Digital so we're not making
fun of you we're just pointing out that
digital is already a very much a way of
life and so don't panic and no there's
no credible indicators that the
government is going to do away with
paper money I think this was there is
some incredible indicators are going to
go away with a penny because it costs
more than a penny to make one right and
man it does literally yeah they're
losing money producing pennies that
nobody uses correct you know and so
um you know so we probably are going to
see some of that but there's some
discussion about
um digital currencies and I think this
when the when the Bitcoin thing went
crazy those who were deep in all new
it's going to go bankrupt it's the
technology that's going to be cool down
the road yeah the technology is probably
going to end up usable fine that's I
mean all just like I imagine there was a
hubbub when they quit when the debit
card came out and then direct deposit
came out and I I think there's always a
lag on that kind of technology and is
what it is and there should have been a
hubbub when the IRS had the unbelievable
genius move to withhold your taxes from
your check before you over got your
check
that was genius yes that got that
created a whole country of sheep yep and
because I got to tell you people if
y'all had to go line up somewhere and
hand hundred dollar bills to someone
called a tax collector for your taxes
out of your check every week there would
be a revolution oh baby it would be
there would be like pitchforks and burn
the monster I mean it would be you know
torches can you imagine oh I that's but
that's how genius this transfer idea is
hey we'll take care we got you yeah it's
a low friction we're gonna make this
easy for you to pay your taxes and then
you can just go to sleep and we will
take all your money well I remember
during covid when
they said hey we'll just deposit it for
you yeah and I thought oh if they can
just put it in there they can just take
it out of there oh there you go paranoia
oh yeah there you go yeah I told you
there's a prepper down in there oh he's
way down in there but he's there but hey
uh and I've talked about this on the
show before uh Wesley for those of you
thinking about investing in gold or
silver
here's the reality um and this comes
from a great quote from one of my
closest buddies who works in banking
there in Texas
if it actually all goes down
if we are if if we are trading coffee
and bullets
we have this idea that our lives are
going to go on as they are like we're
going to go to the gas station in our
car on the way to our jobs and we're
going to hand a canister of bullets and
coffee in exchange for the gas
if we get there where we are trading
gold coins yep
your neighbor will have already shot you
for your water and you will have already
like you're eating pets like everything
is different at this point and so we
stop falling for the you know what when
it all goes down you're going to want to
trade gold bullion for your for what
it's not it's not going to work that way
there's no failed economy in the history
since the Roman Empire that has used
gold as a method of exchange
because of a failed economy no never
once and if they find out you got it
once they'll come get it not once right
no that's not the Hedge know your
neighbors that's the can of gas some new
blue jeans bullets and coffee yeah those
are the that's the barter economy is
what happens in a failed economy and
then a new regime comes up and they
create new paper money with their face
on it this is the Ramsay show